now our next speaker has is a repeat
speaker she spoke
at this conference before she spoke at
the dc
conference and she's spoken at the
meetup so she's very deeply involved
with this community
and she had her wedding in ecuador
fairly recently so please
welcome to the stage luda
all right um hi i'm ludmila yonda i work
at amplify and today i'm going to talk
to you about some work
i did with our our ladies nyc data
um from meetup so what is our ladies
um our ladies is a
global network of meetups
uh you can see here from this shiny
dashboard built by
our ladies that we have 173 chapters
and nearly 70 000 members in 50
countries across the world
um and here you can see from our active
chapters
across the world uh it's pretty exciting
and i just want to point out here that
we even have a chapter
in the galapagos which i found out about
when um
i was actually in the galapagos which
was pretty cool
um so and the whole purpose of our
ladies is to provide
a supportive community for gender
minorities using r
so today
uh so sorry what is this talk um so this
talk is going to be an exploration of
the our ladies nyc meetup data
um an attempt to kind of understand
uh our uh
like ha our members uh who's attending
our events
uh what events are drawing people if
people are coming repeatedly things like
that
um to kind of get a better sense of uh
our our meetup in general and um it's
also a look at the code used to do this
so
hopefully maybe you'll see some cool
packages or functions or just
see an approach that might be
interesting to you that i took
in this process um
so first the first thing i want to talk
about is this meetup r
package uh there's a link here in my
slides uh
to the package this package was made by
our ladies and a couple other
contributors contributors as well i
wasn't involved in the
package making process but i'm excited
to use it
um so this meet up our package takes
advantage of the
meetup api and uses the oauth system in
order to pull data it has several
functions that i'm going to talk about
uh but this first function that i'm
going to talk about is this get events
function
it takes the parameter of the url of the
meetup that you're interested in so
in this case i'm talking about our
ladies new york and it also takes a
parameter
of um you know whether or not you want
a specific event or if you want all the
past events
um and it gives you here you can see all
the variables that it gives you
uh notably for this talk we get all of
the rsvp
counts uh for a yes rsvp
we get the date of the event and some
information about the venue as well
and each event has its own specific id
um so i think one thing i want to point
out is that we don't actually collect
data
about the number of people that attend
our events we don't have that we just
have the number of people that rsvp'd so
there's a little distinction there but i
think
usually you know there's a little
attrition for each event but it's pretty
consistent across the events unless
there's maybe particularly bad weather
on uh on an event day typically
uh we'll see pretty consistent uh
attendance
so um the first thing that i wanted to
do
here was just see how many events we've
had since uh we started in 2016.
so we've had 47 events um
and then i wanted to see kind of just
you know
summary stats of our rsvp counts one
thing i want to point out here is that
there is a ceiling effect here because
we um we are limited in terms of the
venue capacity
so um i guess if we ever
do or when we start meeting again in
person if you have a large venue
and you're interested in hosting us that
would be awesome um
but first i just wanted to look at these
numbers and make a quick graph
um and one thing i wanted to look at is
rrsp
count rsvp counts trending upwards
so i made this graph and i saw that
actually it looks like uh
you know rsvp counts are super jumpy and
there's some really low ones so i got
curious what are these low events
so i went ahead and just labeled events
with
uh less than 35 uh rsvps
and uh oh i want to point out this theme
our ladies is not an official ggplot
uh theme i made it myself um it's in
it's in the code for my slides which
i'll post uh
so this is just something that i made
not official uh
so uh as soon as i made this uh
graph i realized really quickly that
these really low events most of them are
book club events and our book club
events are typically
um they're held in a bookstore
so the capacity is really low and also
uh you know they're usually on a weekend
afternoon so
typically people are some people want to
use that time
differently um so i also saw that
there's a social
and um a workshop and those events just
we tend to keep them small in general so
i decided to go ahead and filter those
out
um and just uh saw that once i did that
our uh media and rsvp count went up by
about 10 people
and um it looks like we're kind of
trending up
and and i think this event here was a
particularly low capacity venue
as well um but kind of good to see that
we're having a lot of events with high
rsvp counts especially
uh you know later on in our existence as
we grow
so then you're curious what are those
popular events i went ahead and labeled
the graph again
but here um with events with more than
80
rsvp uh rsvps um
and got to see that i was happy to see
that a lot of these events
were kind of are kind of later on and
several of them are
online events that we've had since the
beginning of coven 19 which is nice
because we've been really concerned
about
trying to maintain our community during
this time so it's nice to see
that we have a lot of people interested
in coming to events
even though they aren't in person um
and uh i want to point out those events
also have a capacity of 100 people
right now so there is a ceiling effect
there as well all right
so then i wanted to look at our members
data so
one thing i want to point out here is
that when you join meetup you get a
persistent id
that stays with you through each meet up
event
that you attend um
and uh we can pull date on our members
so first we just wanted to see how many
members we have that are active we have
hundred and fifty six oh and i wanna
point out this is
another function in the meet up our
package the get members
function that also uses the parameter of
the url name
um so
uh
so first the first thing i wanted to do
is to just
um go ahead and look at
the account of members that we new
members that we got by month
uh and i made that and i don't see like
any interesting
trends and particularly here it's kind
of jumpy
um so then i got kind of curious um
about are there
of particular events that are drawing a
lot of
new members and i decided to
uh graph that so in order to do that is
a little bit complicated
uh because i needed i needed to join our
members data set with our events data
set and um the first thing i wanted to
do
or i needed to do was to just group by
uh the date um for all of the
for the members data set and get account
of new members for each day
um and i want to point out that we don't
have the full set of dates for the
entire time period in that data set we
just have the days where we got new
members
but if i joined this with our events
data i wanted to make sure not to
that no dates from the events data
dropped out
so um the kind of easy way to do that
what an easy way to do that was to use
this complete function
complete is from tidyar it's a cool
function that i've learned about
recently that lets you complete a set of
observations
uh you know given uh some information
about them so in this case i wanted to
complete
all the possible dates in that time
period from the min
um to the max of our time um
and then i made a quick a little events
data set
um just with the date and the name of
the event
um so then i joined those two data
sets and i in order to get the count of
people
that joined before each event i
grouped um i created a flag
for the for the dates that had events
and i just used a cumulative sum and
here i subtract that event flag from it
because i wanted
the day of the event to be included in
the that event group because they saw a
lot of people actually join
or become members the day of our events
which i thought was interesting
um and wanted to make sure they got in
i'm pretty sure they're joining because
of that event so i wanted them to be
included in that group
uh so then i uh group by the event group
and get the count of new members before
each event um you know when i do this
i lose the the event name and date uh so
i
kind of do the same process but uh just
get the
distinct event group name and date and
join those two data sets together
um and then i'm just going to label all
of our events that had
more than 15 new members before joining
um and so uh here is the
graph code and here you can see so
um every line or
every bar is a event and the height of
the event corresponds to the number of
new members that we got before
each uh before each of these events uh
which is
you know this is uh interesting to see i
think in some cases like here there's
just a lot of time between events so a
lot of people could join
but then in some cases uh you know we
see that a lot of people got
drawn in um uh
because potentially because of a
specific event
um and uh
in particular i got interested in
whether or not um
hadley wickham's talk that he gave to
our meetup brought in a lot of new
members
uh so i wanted to see if there was a
bump there and it looks like there was
um it wasn't our biggest bump um
but it looks like he did bring in a lot
of new members which is cool
uh not very surprising of course um so
the next thing i wanted to do
um so was just look at all
of our um uh you know member counts for
every day leading up to an event
just kind of zoom out and look at that
bigger picture
um this isn't as easy to see
just because you have a ton of data
graphed on top of each other but i
faceted it by year uh each
uh purple line is the day of an event
and here you can actually see that we
get a lot of new members
once again the height of the bar is
corresponding to the number of new
members
so you can see we do get a lot of new
members the day of the event
um and often like a lot of new members
right before it as well
although i saw in some cases we get new
members right after an event
um as well so maybe people uh
went to an event and uh had a great time
told some friends about it
or heard about an upcoming talk that
might be uh
interesting and told friends about it
and they joined
so potentially can't just attribute um
the uh new members before the event
uh to the uh accounts
sorry my dog is being a little crazy
okay
so the next thing i was interested in
was
loyalty i wanted to see how much are
people coming to our events repeatedly
so i used this meetup function called
get event attendees and once again it
takes that url
url name parameter um but it
specifically takes a parameter for
just one event but i wanted the data
about all of our events because i wanted
to see how much people are coming
multiple times so in order to do that i
i got all of our event ids and then i
used them
from per the map dfr function in order
to
um row bind data frames of all of the
you know iterate uh across
pulling all of the data sets from of our
event attendees for every event and
rebind them together so i'd have one
nice data set
quickly um
all right so once i got that i
went ahead and um grouped by
each user's id that persistent id that
they have
and um i also filled and got the count
of events that they rsvp
too i also filtered down to just
people that joined prior to this year
because
um people that joined this year we
haven't had a ton of events and they
haven't had a chance to
go um to several events when i made a
graph and i saw
actually a lot of people are coming um
maybe once
or rsvping once or twice to our events
um but at the same time there is this
nice long tail where we have
a you know good amount of people that
are actually going
rsvp'ing to several events i also saw
that we had this one
um outlier and
um i then went i got curious about how
many events
i rsvp'd to so i looked up my um
my meetup id and um
looked at how many um i had rsvp2 and it
turns out that i
am that outlier so you can see my
passion for our ladies
uh clearly quantified here
um so the next thing i wanted to do is
get a map of our event locations and i
was particularly
interested in this because um
we are really concerned about making
sure that our events are
somewhere central easy to access and
um you know kind of spread out a little
bit over
um our area and
um so i went ahead and uh
graphed that and as you can see i think
we did a good job here i think we've got
um you know most of our events are
pretty central to manhattan or in
locations that are fairly accessible we
had one in brooklyn but really close to
manhattan
close to some trains one or a couple up
at columbia but
i'm once again close to some trains so i
i felt good about that i thought that
was great
um so what do i want to do next with
this um
next i want to make a flex dashboard
another one of our board members
keon mineros uh gave a great
talk uh about flex dashboards recently
they inspired me
to make a flex dashboard and i think it
would be really great for us
um to be able to uh you know look at it
um and uh
kind of look at it regularly as a board
and get some insights
about um about us and then
another thing i want to do is i want to
use the functions for meetup r to
automate our website event posts we have
a website built in our of course
and um but whenever we have an a new
event we kind of
manually copy paste what we post and
meet up into
our website and i think it'd be cool to
just pull that information
using the meet up our package and
automate that process
i also want to use uh use this data kind
of can
consider more who our speakers are and
if we're involving our community
uh well kind of think more about how we
can do that
in a meaningful way um
and then the i want to leave you with
the last thing i know word clouds are
kind of a
frivolous data visualization but this is
a word cloud
of the comments left on our meetup page
and i think it's a nice uh
place to leave us because it looks like
a lot of people said thank you
and i want to say thank you to all of
you for attending
um i also want to thank sebastian my
husband for
listening to my talk several times my
mother as well who's
also in our lady um my manager at
amplify who
gave me the idea to write this talk and
also recruited me from an our ladies
event
um and also to ayanthi another one of
our board members who helped me make
that map i did a horrible job making
uh the map in the first place know
nothing about making maps the projection
was all off and she helped me
even gave me the right shape files she
was super helpful
um and then thank you so much to the
wonderful our ladies
nyc thank you all
thank you luda for sharing that
data-driven look into our ladies that
was really awesome
before we head to break i wanted to tell
everyone about
a tradition we started a few years ago
and we have
expanded it this year i'm gonna share my
screen